des crimes terrifiants des années
d'omerta et un fiasco judiciaire c'est
le retour de la série événement la
conspiration du
silence avec son réalisateur Thierry
Fournet 23 ans d'investigation et
toujours cette quête de vérité les
femmes
disparaissent les unes après les autres
on va dire sans que les institutions
dont elle p souvent la presque toujours
la même d'ailleurs ne s'y
intéresse des
témoignagesid moi ça me fait toujours
quelque chose jeense à ça des archives
jamais dévoilé les CL pour tout
comprendre sur cette affaire qui est
clabous
Lyon la trque est le procès de l'un des
plus célèbres tueurs en
[Musique]
sérieouour comment il a suivi de près ce
qui reste comme une déflagration dans la
ville
d'osser la première chose qui était le
déclencheur c'est la découverte d'un
corps à rouvré sous ce tas de
fumier puis nous irons rejoindre Corin
Herman l'avocate emblématique qui n'a
jamais rien lâché toujours au service
des familles de victimes se battant sans
relâche on a entendu des victimes qui
étaient euh inaudible qui étaient des
jeunes femmes handicapées mentales qui
avaient été placées à la dase qui
n'existait pas en terme de société la
conspiration du silence saison 2
l'enquête
[Musique]
continue
Thierry Fournet là quand vous vous
baladez dans la ville d'osser qu'est-ce
que vous ressentez et à qui vous pensez
alors qu'est-ce que je ressens
c'est c'est Multiple parce que ça fait
25 ans que je j'arpente ces ru là un
petit peu donc vraiment quand je
remarque surtout cette rue là qui est en
fait la rue centrale d'osser bah voilà
ça me fait penser à ça à ces femmes qui
ont disparu et dont on connaît peu de
choses finalement toute une partie leur
vie et dans l'ombre personne s'y est
intéressé et encore aujourd'hui ça
arrive donc pour moi c'est c'est
vraiment ce qui me restera de ces
promenades dans le
SER à l'époque c'est une affaire
complètement inconnue du grand public
oui c'est une affaire curieusement
inconnue jusqu'à l'émission de TF1 perdu
de vue he qui effectivement s'intéresse
là à ces femmes qui ont disparu à partir
de là on va commencer à chercher à
savoir mais jusque là c'est un mystère
complet et on peut estimer qu'entre 28
et 30 femmes ont disparu comme ça sans
qu'on sache vraiment ce qu'elles sont
devenu quoi et là ça pose vraiment des
problèmes au niveau des institutions
quel qu'elles
soit parce que tout commence en fait ici
dans cette petite ville de province
tranquille au à la fin des années 70
c'est ça les femmes disparaissent les
unes après les autres on va dire sans
que les institutions dont elles
dépendent souvent la DAS presque
toujours la DAS même d'ailleurs ne s'y
intéresse les directeurs d'institution
s'y intéressent pas non plus lorsque par
hasard ça dépasse un peu leur domaine et
que ça arrive dans les mains d'un
policier ou d'un gendarme on s'y
intéresse peu jusqu'à ce qu'un jour un
gendarme Christian Jambert lui parce que
lui-même d'ailleurs est issu de la DAS
décide vraiment de s'y intéresser c'est
lui qui va permettre toute cette affaire
de de sortir j'ai fait une enquête
disons non officiel parce que c'était
des filles de laadas je me suis entêté
et je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait
c'était des disparitions suspectes parce
que ces filleslà n'ont jamais réapparu
alors vous décidez d'en faire une série
pour sortir de l'oubli toutes ces jeunes
femme ça devient votre quête de vérité
oui d'abord on est deux hein V RC et moi
c'était intéressant parce que lui
n'avait pas suivi ces affaires là à
cette époque là donc ça permettait
d'avoir un dou le regard un regard
historique sur tout ça mais aussi un
regard nouveau sur comment appréhender
aujourd'hui ce qui s'était passé il y a
il y a 20 ans et ça je trouve que c'est
très enrichissant parce que c'est pas
les mêmes questions qu'on se posait et
je pense que le fait de décider aussi
c'était une idée de France I Dijon de
retraiter cette affaire mais avec un
regard différent avec du recul en
laissant les gens s'exprimer plus
longtemps et en étudiant plus que les
fêtes la société autour comment c'est
possible que des choses comme ça soient
arrivées dans les années 70 et 80 23 ans
d'enquête pour vous plus qu'un travail
de journaliste c'est un travail
d'enquêteur de police que vous avez fait
on pourrait dire d'entomologiste aussi
presque c'est essayer d'étudier qu'une
loupe ce qui s'est passé dans ces
familles là dans ces institutions moi
c'est ça qui m'a intéressé le plus les
faits c'est une chose on les découvre on
arrive à résoudre ou à savoir qui a fait
ça qui mais c'est pas ça l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est d'étudier comment la
société a fonctionné et pourquoi c'est
possible pour espérer qu'aujourd'hui ça
n'arrive plus et je suis pas sûr que ça
n'arrive plus aujourd'hui alors vous
avez arpenté cette ville d'osser et les
20 km aux alentours depuis des années
vous avez entendu plusieurs témoins les
familles de victimes des gens qui
n'avaient jamais parlé pourquoi ils ont
parlé avec vous pourquoi ils ont voulu
vous parler à vous on a trouvé des des
témoins qui avaient jamais parlé à aucun
journaliste parce qu'aucun journaliste
était vraiment intéressé à leur position
sont des gens de tous les jours et ça du
coup je trouve que ça donne un relief un
peu différ différent une vue de
l'extérieur une vue de la société est-ce
que c'est pas aussi parce qu'ils ont
trouvé quelqu'un qui les écoutait
vraiment plus que les entendre peut-être
oui qu'on a passé du temps à les écouter
à chaque fois avant d'interviewer un
personnage bah on allait parler avec lui
pendant le repérage souvent plusieurs
fois et puis moi aussi me j'avais dans
la tête cette idée du droit à l'oubli
c'est que est-ce que ces gens-là on va
rouvrir des PL reparler à nouveau de ces
affaires va ouvrir des PL donc il faut
que ça serve à quelque chose si si on
rouvre des plas pour rien même chez les
même chez les du côté des victimes
certes mais même de l'autre côté hein
les enfants d'Émil Louis par exemple
j'ai rencontré son son fils l'un de ses
fils c'était intéressant de savoir
comment il réagissait à ça voilà est-ce
que pour lui c'est honnête ce qu'on a
fait et cetera même de leur côté à eux
et je trouve que voilà c'est ça qui m'a
qui m'a intéressé c'est le le contact
avec tous ces personnages bonjour
monsieur voilà je je m'appelle Thierry
Fournet en fait j'essayais de vous
contacter concernant la disparition de
votre mère et je voulais savoir si vous
aviez des renseignements là-dessus 23
ans d'enquête des centaines d'interviews
on imagine des refus des obstacles aussi
est-ce que vous Thierry Fournet vous
êtes fatigué de tout ça ou est-ce que
vous vous dites je vais continuer le
combat alors continuer le combat oui pas
forcément au même endroit toujours quoi
je il y a pas qu'oser qu' se passe des
choses comme celles-là je crois que
c'est difficile d'abandonner tous ces
gens-là quoi aujourd'hui on a retrouvé
d'autres d'autres victimes donc bon ben
voilà qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec cette
situation est-ce qu'on essae de les
aider aussi à dépasser tout ça parce que
parfois nous parler pour eux c'est
presque une psychothérapie je veux dire
ils parle de leurs problèmes on les
écoute on passe du temps et c'est
uniquement pour ça aussi la différence
avec un reportage classique je crois
c'est le temps passer avec les gens
c'est sûr que on narrive pas une heure
après c'est fini c'est vraiment
plusieurs fois des rencontres en lig
interview et là du coup ça mène une
proximité différente une confiance je
pense différente la conspiration du
silence la première saison est sorti il
y a un an avec un un écho national sur
France 3 dans les dans les médias quels
ont été les retours ici à oser et dans
Lyonne alors c'est difficile à savoir
moi je le sais par les personnages
évidemment qu'on a traité je pense que
ça a été finalement assez bien reçu par
les gens je craignais un peu qu'il a
cette idée chez les ocerrois de se dire
ça y est on repart enc DEES affaires on
nous remetouis on nous remetunant et cet
je pense que la façon dont on a fait le
magazine a fait que les gens sont
intéressés c'est l'impression c'est les
retours que j'ai eu maintenant tout le
monde a pas forcément cet avis là mais
je trouve que ça a été assez bien
accepté et que les gens s'y sont
intéressés je je crois mais je peux me
tromper c'est une affaire sensible
terriblement sensible encore ah oui je
me souviens d'une fois faisait le
portrait de Pierre monoir et on a fait
un petit micro trottoir dans cette rue
un peu plus haut là en demandant aux
gens pour vous est-ce que l'affaire des
disparus de Lyonne qu'est-ce que c'était
est-ce que c'est encore présent les
tris/4 des gens partaient sans vouloir
nous répondre donc c'est encore
sensible on vient vous voir je suis
journaliste j'aimerais discuter avec
vous si c'est non non non écoutez encore
cette affaire là foutez-moi la ça parce
que moi je commence à en avoir part ça
fait plus de 20 ans ouais alors
qu'est-ce qu'on vient de faire chier
encore là puis surtout avec ça avec ça
moi je vous dis franchement je si si je
me retenais pas je prendrai mon puisi je
vous en foutrai un coup voyez j'ai pas
peur de le dire bah écoutez moi je vous
avez pas raison de m'en [__] un coup
d'abord je vous ai je vous ai pas
agressé j'ai rien dit du tout vous avez
été encore menacé ou vous avez encore
subi des pressions non on peut on peut
pas dire ça de cette manière là disons
que des gens qui nous montrent que ça
leur plaît pas oui ça c'est sûr
dépressions pas
vraiment pas vraiment directement en
tous les cas c'estàdire qu'il y a des
choses qui vous revenent aux oreilles
oui c'est ça euh par exemple il y a des
gens qui avaient accepté de nous parler
et puis qui 6 mois plus tard euh
finalement avaient annul ne voulit plus
nous parler bon ça c'est on l'a vu
plusieurs fois mais globalement je
trouve quand même que que non les les
les gens ont assez facilement accepté de
nous reparler de tout ça malgré tout
même si ça leur en coûtait piierry
fournais si les murs qui nous entourent
pouvaient parler là qu'est-ce qu'il
pourrait nous révéler h alors ce serait
intéressant de toute manière parce qu'il
reste malgré tout beaucoup de mystères
sur toutes ces histoires hein euh par
par exemple sur l'affaire du N où aucun
des clients n'a payé ni même n'a été
identifié donc ça c'est c'est quand même
dur
hein et puis même autour de l'affaire mi
Louis cette lettre qu'il a reçu dans le
Var de quelqu'un d'ici d'ser le
prévenant que attention on lui cherchait
des pous dans la tête il fallait que ce
soit quelqu'un proche ou de la police ou
de la justice pour pouvoir le prévenir
de ça on n' jamais su qui c'était il
reste beaucoup oup de mystère alors des
zones d'ombres avec justement des
révélations à la fin de cette saison que
vous allez nous faire de nouveaux faits
concernant émil Louis oui
oui d'abord parce que est-ce que est-ce
qu'on a tout découvert concernant em
Louis non il reste quand même une
certaine certain nombre de questions qui
se posent et en particulier est-ce qu'il
a est-ce qu'il n'a tué que 7 h personnes
bah non il s'avère que probablement il
en a tué plus donc ça c'est c'est aussi
de nouvelles tion et on a un peu
l'impression qu'on en finirait jamais
hein de trouver de nouvelles choses il
reste des choses à trouver qu'est-ce qui
manque pour connaître la vérité
maintenant ce sera à mon avis très
difficile parce que le temps à la
rivière de l'eau est passé sous les pont
le temps le temps a fait son œuvre et ça
devient difficile de travailler sur des
affaires qui ont qui ont 25 ans donc je
pense que là si faait des des
révélations de gens qui prochent de leur
fa admettons proche de leur mort se
décide à parler par exle non non
personnellement j'y crois pas mais
saiton jamais il peut y avoir des gens
qui ont envie de changer les choses moi
personnellement j'y crois pas beaucoup
puis même on a l'impression qu' quand
même une pesanteur de la part des des
responsables politiques ici quel qu'il
soit qui cherch pas forcément à vouloir
faire la lumière ça veut dire quoi ça je
pense que bon évidemment ils ont
l'impression que de reparler de ça ça
donne une mauvaise les images de la
ville et non c'est pas vrai parce qu'une
fois que la vérité est découverte voilà
c'est c'est différent je pense qu'il y a
ça c'est un petit peu l'omerta quoi la
loi du silence on parle pas de ce qui ce
qui gêne on veut pas se donner une
mauvaise image et on parle pas de ce qui
gêne cette série tiieré fournaet vous
auriez pu la faire il y a 10
ans je pense pas c'est une c'est une
bonne question mais je pense pas parce
que aujourd'hui on a le recul nécessaire
pour étudier toute cette affaire il y a
10 ans ça aurait été peut-être un peu
trop pas vif alors bien sûr par exemple
sur Christian Jambert comment il est
mort là aussi c'est un mystère peut-être
qu'il y a 10 ans on aurait pu avancer
plus sûrement parce qu'on était plus
proche du moment où se sont passés les
faits mais sinon je pense qu'on aurait
pas pu faire une série aussi forte sur
le fond aussi documenté avec des
personnages un peu extérieurs à
l'affaire non je je pense que c'était le
bon moment pour le faire est-ce que ça
continuera ou pas je sais pas à priori
je pense que non quand
j'aurais plutôt tendance à dire que
j'aimerais bien tourner la page quand
[Musique]
même dans les années 90 Gérard delorm
était journaliste pour le quotidien
régional Lyon
républicaine il a suivi de près presque
jour par jour l'affaire des disparus de
Lyonne je crois qu'il y a eu une série
de dysfonctionnement je crois qu'il y a
eu plus du laisser aller
euh des maladresse que la volonté
d'étouffer une affaire je ne crois pas
du tout à la volonté d'étouffer une
affaire c'est une affaire que les
autorités ont longtemps négliger voir
étouffer les disparus de Lyonne à quel
moment votre journal décide de traiter
ce F
les disparus de liyonne on les a connu
qu'à partir de l'émission perdu de vue
en 1996 en 1996 c'est vrai que au moment
de de cette disparition on ne le savait
pas déjà dans les années 80 on avait
effectivement miteran venait d'être élu
il y avait tout un changement aussi au
niveau des médias la gocer avait été en
finale de la Coupe de France ensuite
c'était l'accession première division et
on parlait plus de foot des choses qui
allaient bien la reine Élizabeth était
venue à vessel en 79 voyez donc on avait
tout un tas d'actualités intéressantes à
ce niveau-là qui valorisaent le
département de Lyonne après ces affaires
là on les connaissait pas la première
chose qui étéit le déclencheur c'est la
découverte d'un corps à rouvré sous ce
tas de
fumier et ça c'était en 80 vous voyez et
jusque là il y avait pas du tout
d'information et c'est à partir de ce
moment-là qu'on a parlé desmouis donc à
quel moment vous vous dites vous
professionnel journaliste on a une
affaire on a plusieurs disparitions on a
peut-être un tueur en série le premier
papier que j'ai fait sur il Louis
c'était en 92 début 82 quand il a été
arrêté pour la première fois assignloù
il résidait d'ailleurs le titre c'était
ilouis entre le vis et la vertu donc
c'était déjà quelque chose il y avait un
doute et on disait que derrière ces
affaires de d'attouchement et cetera ça
pouvait être beaucoup plus grave mais
enprès ça n'a pas il y a pas eu de suite
puisqu'il a été sur laaffaire le sage on
n'a pas tenu compte du tout du rapport
jeanbert par exemple qui pensait que
c'était lui le coupable il a eu un
nonlieu sur l'affaire le sage il a pas
été condamné pour cette affaire là il
était condamné pour des attouchements au
tribunal à la même époque en 83 je crois
sur trois jeunes filles qui étaient
gardé par sa concubine je pas un
criminel je pas un assassin c'est tout
ce que je veux vous dire pas plus qu'un
violeur et encore bien moins pédophile
certains on les avait dit
pour bien comprendre justement votre
travail vous journaliste à l'époque
comment vous procédez on avait notre
travail avec les informateurs habituels
qui sont la police la gendarmerie ont
vérifié auprès des des tribunaux comme
aujourd'hui et on avait surtout un
réseau de correspondant important sur le
département qui étaiit nos premiers
informateurs on disait les correspondans
c'est les yeux et les oreilles du
journal et l'affaire l'arrestation des
Milou à sign fin entre noël et jour de
l'an 81 on l'a su par notre
correspondant local la signolé moi à
cette époque je travaillais quelque fois
le soir et j'ai rencontré jeanbert au
nickibar justement le le bar ou alléoui
avec une des sœurs le moine je sais plus
laquelle et on en parlait mais c'est
vrai qu' janbert faisait une fixation
surou il avait raison la dernière fois
on a vu ma sœur ce monsieur devait
l'emmener dans une petite ville
avoisinante à Vallon dans un travail où
elle devait qu'elle devait effectuer
là-bas on a eu quelques doutes aussi he
par rapport comm comme beaucoup par
rapport à mission perdu de vue vous
savez c'était pas évident non plus il y
avait pas mal de voyurisme c'était pas
considéré comme une émission
véritablement sérieuse et on a découvert
en même temps que le grand public cette
affaire des disparu c'est là qu'on a eu
connaissance des photos des familles
aussi des familles de des victimes qui
sont intervenu avec Pierre maunoir et
Janette beaufumet sur cette affaire
c'est à partir de là que les disparus de
Lyon ont véritablement existé dans
l'esprit des gens attendez il y a eu
l'émission à la télé là avec l'autre con
là comment qui s'appela hein perdu de
vue avec Pradel ouais il m'a jamais
invité vous y seriez allé
oui oui serait allé pour dire quoi ben
pour dire que j'y suis pour rien on
arrête de de me soupçonner de de
m'accuser de m'accuser
surtout quels sont les réaction alors à
ce moment-là dans la ville dans le
département alors à ce momentlà dans le
département c'est vrai que on y croyait
pas trop déjà les gens avaient le le
sentiment ça pesait quand même
lourdement sur l'image du département
alors que c'était les disparus d'Er le
président du conseil général à l'époque
trouvait que c'était qu'on en faisait
beaucoup sur cette affaire sat ternisait
l'image du département je vois pas quel
homme politique aurait pris la
responsabilité de dissimuler quoi que ce
soit alors qu'en face il y avait des
disparitions de d'un certain nombre de
jeunes femmes je veux dire dire que
c'est disproportionné ça peut pas
exister ça est-ce qu'avec le recul vous
diriez qu'il y a bien eu une
conspiration du silence il y a eu oui
dans dans dans un dans un noyau précis
émil Louis protégé par un réseau de
notable est-ce que ça vous paraît
possible ça c'est possible c'est
possible mais mais je crois qu'ils
étaient dans un milieu hein moi je crois
qu'il faut pas se cacher la vérité il y
avait aussi la franc-maçonnerie derrière
il y avait une fraternité si j'ose dire
au sens noble du terme entre ces
personnes-là et c'est vrai que au sein
de la structure àage notamment ils
étaient très très solidaires dans dans
ce cadre- làà iloui dans cet univers il
était jamais pris à
défaut est-ce que vous avez des regrets
vous Gérard Delor mais ce que vous vous
dites là 30 ans après j'ai fait des
erreurs moi journaliste bon on fait
toujours des erreurs à postériori on dit
on aurait peut-être pu suivre davantage
janbert pousser l'institution et je
crois que c'était pas dans la façon de
travailler de l'époque aussi hein on
nétait pas la à la course au scoop comme
on peut l'être aujourd'hui justement
avec avec ces chaînes d'information
continue il faut donner de l'information
parce qu'on a un créneau pour donner de
l'information donc on avait plus de
distance qu'on pouvait qu'on peut
l'avoir aujourd'hui et et c'est vrai
qu'on a toujours des regrets parce qu'on
on est passé à côté de quelque chose
alors on est Auer ici aujourd'hui avec
vous est-ce que c'est toujours un
traumatisme dans la ville surtout qu'on
sait que toute la lumière n'a pas été
faite ouais je pense moins quand même
parce qu'il y a nouvelle
génération les disparitions ça fait plus
de 40 ans maintenant le jugement d'é
milouis ça fait plus de 20 ans et pour
les anciens oui ça reste quelque chose
encore qui qui les marque moi je vois
bien quand on a vu l'émission moi
j'habite à Avallon il y a des gens
d'Avallon qui m'ont parlé des affaires
parce qu' ils les ont revu donc ça a
quand même marqué pas simplement au mais
tout le territoire tout le département
de Lyonne mais je pense que les
nouvelles générations par contre sont
beaucoup plus distantes par rapport à
ces affaires
[Musique]
he go
W des fois il manger là ça c'est
toujours très bien
[Musique]
pensé ces affaires criminelles Corin
Herman les cô toi de près depuis 27 ans
cet avocat déterminé traque avec une
implacable rigueur les plus grands
tueurs avec un light motif être toujours
au service des familles de victimes
qu'elle défend avec force
force presque 30 ans vous côtoyez les
plus grands criminels français qu'est-ce
qu'il y a dans la tête d'un tueur en
série je pense que il y a des choses
terribles dans la tête de ces tueurs là
et par définition on n'est pas nous-même
des tueurs et des tueurs
multirécidivistes donc c'est difficile
de rentrer dans leur
tête il faut absolument tout connaître
tout travailler tout connaître de leur
histoire tout connaître de l'histoire
des victimes tout connaître des acts qui
ont été commis avant d'identifier
l'auteur pour pouvoir comprendre pour
pouvoir redessiner le parcours de la
victime le parcours de l'auteur et cette
rencontre terrible et pour pouvoir la
comprendre il va nous montrer les sept
emplacements qu'il désigne pour avoir
entért les SEP corps des jeunes
filles sur la scène de crime dans les
acts qui ont été commis l'auteur il
s'inspire de son histoire je dirais que
c'est la photographie de son son
histoire et de sa vie et c'est aussi ce
qui nous permet d'être sûr d'être devant
la belle personne ça n'est pas seulement
les les aveux ça n'est pas seulement ce
qu'il veut bien nous dire ou pas ou ce
que vont nous dire les preuves
matérielles ou ce que vont nous dire les
proches c'est que sur la scène de crime
sur la victime on a obligatoirement
l'histoire de l'auteur et si on connaît
bien son histoire on trouve ces trace
sur la scène de crime qui nous montre
qu'on s'est pas
trompé je pense que oui mile Louis et
l'assassin il vient le sage également
le corps de cvien leage durant est
découvert avec les mains attachées dans
le dos avec un nœud marin avec un
collant dans la bouche et on découvre
Jacqueline ves les ossement des mains
dans le dos avec un nœud marin et avec
un slip et un collant dans la bouche C
appartiennentil au disparus des
expertises ADN sont en cours pour le
déterminer connaîre maintenant laadn et
si laadn il y a rien qu'est-ce qu'on
fait alors alors 2004 procèdém Louis à
haoser c'est la première fois que vous
voyez comment
est-il d'abord il dégage une force
incroyable contrairement à ce qu'on on
pourrait penser quand on voit les photos
les images il a une présence vraiment
intense ce qui est pas le cas de tous
les tu en série parce que Michel fournir
l'a pas de présence justement c'est
l'impression
d'avoir même pas une personne face à par
moment que
mil Louis il a ce côté un peu à la Gabin
il a une goaille il a une façon de
parler et puis il a un physique qui
l'utilise et quand il se présente je
m'attendais pas à ça j'avais une autre
image de lui et cette force là qui
dégage je comprends tout de suite quand
il rentre dans la cour d'assise qu' va
d'abord se battre et que cette présence
là elle est plus proche de de l'homme
que les victimeses ont rencontré que cet
homme qui les a un petit peu
emboubiné et puis qui ensuite ite les a
agressé on voit qu'il y a il y a une
force qui nous fait mesurer ce que ces
victimes on en tout cas les jeunes
femmes qui étaient avec lui on peut on
pu affronter
mile Louis vous en avez entendu parler
ah mais oui mais oui comment vous l'avez
rencontré bah il amené ma fille m'a
affiché la logeuse c'est comme ça que
j'ai connu on lui a donné bon Dieu sans
confession
celui-là je n'arrive pas à définir les
pulsions que j'avais c'était
principalement pendant le printemps et
l'été
alors c'est un enfant de laade abandonné
violé lui aussi il évoque je cite la
bestiole avec des pulsions qu'il ne
saurait pas contrôler alors il est pas
le premier à invoquer cela mais vous
acceptez vous admettez vous cette idée
en tant qu'avocate au début je me dis il
se moque de nous et il veut mettre ça se
dégager de sa responsabilité mais
n'empêche que la bestiole elle est avec
lui donc c'est bien que c'est lui qui
est là donc déjà c'est une forme d'aveu
et ensuite c'est cette impossibilité à
raconter des faits qu'on a commis dans
un un état certains PS parlent de
presque comme dans un shoot comment
expliquer ce qui vous a pris ce que vous
avez fait donc la bestiole c'est
finalement une explication c'est une
partie de lui qui agit à ce moment-là
c'est une façon de nous expliquer donc
au départ ce que je pensais être de
l'ORD de la légende et de l'amusement
finalement c'est c'est plus sérieux
qu'on pense et c'est une forme
[Musique]
d'aveu il va être condamné à la perpété
pour vous c'est une victoire à ce
moment-là une personne qui est condamnée
à perpétuité c'est quelqu'un qui est
rayé de la société et donc dans
l'immédiat tout de suite on a contribué
à ça et donc du coup c'est difficile à
porter quand même et puis ensuite oui
c'est quand même une victoire parce
qu'on entendu des des victimes qui
étaient inaudibles qui étaient des
jeunes femmes handicapées mentales qui
avaient été placé à la DAS qui
n'existaiit pas en terme de société
elles avaient leur réponse et donc oui
c'est une grande victoire parce qu'on
est parti de rien et qu'on a mis du
temps et que ce tueur qui venait comme
ça de long de de très loin des années 70
oui c'était une victoire parce que c'est
un vrai colqu il a été jugé et condamné
mais c'est toujours un constat d'échec
une condamnation à
perpétuité on va le voir à la fin de
cette 2e saison de la conspiration du
silence il reste des zones d'ombre et
des crimes encore non élucidé dans Lyon
il reste beaucoup d'affaires non élucidé
quand on a travaillé très longtemps sur
ces affaires il a longtemps aussi il y a
ple d'affaires qui sont apparues autour
des mil000oui moi j'ai essayé de rester
concentré sur l'affaire des disparus de
Lyonne parce que si je m'étais éparpillé
l'affaire ne sortait pas mais on a
approché entendu vu il y a eu d'ailleurs
d'autres affaires d'autres d'autres
procès autour la presse a brassé
beaucoup de choses nous a amené aussi
beaucoup d'informations parce que plein
de témoins qui qui viennent se
manifester des gens qui nous ont écrit
on sait qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres
affaires et d'ailleurs en 2001 je sors
un livre sur l'affaire des disparus de
Lyonne
et à la fin de ce livre je fais la liste
des victimes qui ne sont pas les
victimes des Minoui parce qu'à l'époque
on mettait tout dans le même sac on
avait pas assez de recul en tout cas en
terme médiatique et donc j'explique
qu'il y a d'autres victimes ça n'est pas
le mode opératoire des minouill ça n'est
pas son fonctionnement je le connais
tellement bien que je sais que là non
c'est pas lui parce que c'est pas sa
façon de procéder même si ça ressemble
je m'étais fait beaucoup agresser à
l'époque pour avoir osé écrire que il y
avait ouis mais que derrière ilouis il y
avait d'autres tues en série
probablement et j'avais pas j'avais pas
tort puisquon en a trouvé trois autres
après dans Lyonne et on est bien loin
encore du compte de des affaires non
résolues on sait qu'avec Émile Louis il
y a de potentielles nouvelles victimes
c'est ce qui va être révélé dans la
conspiration du silence alors oui moi je
le sais depuis peu de temps
effectivement on m'a indiqué que il y
avait une possible 9e victime qu'on
connaissait pas qui était pas dans la
liste on connaît d'autres victimes pour
lesquels la justice n'a pas voulu
investiguer qui sont probablement des
victimes des Minoui notamment avant les
disparus de Lyonne et pendant les
disparus de Lyonne mais la justice n'a
pas voulu le faire et on n peut-être pas
su se faire entendre là effectivement
récemment on m'a indiqué qu'il y avait
peut-être la 9e victime desoui dans
Lyonne qui qui venait d'être identifiée
vous êtes surprise non je ne suis pas
surprise parce que je pense qu'à
l'époque on n'a pas quadré déjà
totalement les lieux où il pouvait
offrir des victimes ses lieux à lui son
cimetière personnel je pense qu'on l'a
jamais exploré
totalement
nous a montré une Mar à
bestiau et quand il nous la montre il
s'est trompé à peu près d'une quinzaine
de mètres donc très
peu c'est c'est très classique dans dans
dans l'affaire Michel Fourniret on a eu
un premier procès en 2008 où il y avait
une dizaine de victimes il y a eu un
deuxième procès il y a le troème procès
aujourd'hui où on a tr victime dont deux
qui é qui étaient dans Lyonne et qu'on
connaissait déjà on aura un 4è procès
probablement concernant Michel Fourniret
on n'a pas eu cette chance pour mé Louis
parce que la justice une fois qu'il a
été jugé c'était la tradition à l'époque
elle n'a pas voulu chercher les notres
dossierers n'a pas voulu nous entendre à
la fois sur Draguignan on avait des noms
de victimes et sur Lyon je trouve quand
même que l'enquête elle a pétiné trop
longtemps oui c'tait vrai hein ça trop
long et ben c'est une AM et des
handicapés qui gent alors profitez des
handicapés mais je trouve que la justice
n'a pas été très rapide j'ai une
dernière question au début de cette
affaire vous étiez juriste aujourd'hui
vous êtes avocate est-ce que vous diriez
que c'est grâce à l'affaire des disparus
de Lyon je dirais que c'est à cause de
l'affaire des disparus de Lyonne et moi
j'ai du mal à tourner les yeux quand
j'ai une certitude ou quand j'ai j'ai du
mal à tourner les yeux quand je pense
avoir des réponses à donner à des
familles ou un
suspect sur lequel je je dois travailler
ou j'ai envie de travailler donc c'est
ce qui m'a un peu piégé depuis 27 ans
c'est-à-dire que c'est du provisoire qui
dure depuis 27 ans et passer le pas ça
paraissait naturel à un moment donné un
moment où on m'interdisait d'intervenir
en tant que juriste donc il fallait
passer le
[Musique]
pas
la soirée événement la conspiration du
silence se poursuit sur France 3
Bourgogne Franche compté à suivre dans
un instant les CIN derniers épisodes de
la saison 2 avec de nouvelles
révélations fracassant à nouveau des
femmes oubliées et en ligne de mire un
autre tueur en série Michel
[Musique]
four